type en dépression bougies je dis
pas que tout s'effondre la piscine comme
adjani j'étais fatigué je pense que tu
es fatigué puis des soucis puis la santé
aussi ça n'allait pas trop serré ouais
bah j'en avais marre des
baous je suis vous conseille ça se calme
non c'est vrai ça se calme des quoi les
conseils non non non je
suis également
vous jure que c'est vrai alors tu dis
maintenant la matinée me voir dans ma
loge et fille
commençait alors on paie par caprice de
sculpteurs que j'ai bataillé
avec un ceux ci se sont frottés tu peux
me parlez moi j'ai tout lu
voilà voilà les symptômes ya des moments
tu t'inquiètes pas voilà et je suis
inquiète et non jeudi schifani qui passe
ça va ça vient d'annoncer quoi une
ordonnance bien sûr
nous rembourser on n'a rien coûté à la
sécu n'est
pas mieux aujourd'hui ça va beaucoup
mieux paul je vous dis il a eu un petit
truc et l'upr est sûr c'est qu'elle rate
et du corps calleux coeur le
niveau du cardio exactement mais tous
reconnaissent
que la gnr malades n'ont donc ça a
marché mais bien sûr
ça va il de mettre fin valérie comble
c'est que ça c'est pas par transitivité
compte tenu des trucs quand il était
petit sont pas bien sûr très belle
histoire moi mon père quand il rentrait
il me disait j'ai failli du mal à faire
un créneau
général
le père le père de jack daniel's quand
ils rendraient les badges et chacha
hamamouche
[Rires]
c'est bon ça va chacun voilà chacun et
chacun voit la pro d2
sérieusement avant des compétences en
maître ab oui un jeu pas vraiment
sérieusement socialité vous êtes à peine
je suis alors je suis généraliste
avec une spécialité des maladies
vénériennes
c'est ça oui c'était une belle eau
j'avais même j'ai même plongé un panaris
m'a donné les bons concerts bien sûr
mais l'on ne sait pas ce que tu as c'est
quoi c'est une peine le quart ou un
problème cardio va s'élever le coeur
cardiovasculaires
c'est d'ailleurs j'ai écouté son coeur
je vais pas sortir c'est au scope
dommage si et comment
vous vous moquez mais l'équipe et
l'envoyer quoi vous sert à cette hausse
coop à vous mais je suis médecin
c'est très original
je n'ai pas entendu j'étais pas enlever
toutes ses passions béton plus alors
bien sûr là je me dis que je n'ai tous
nos regards des voyages j'ai vu qu'il
était médecin je suis rentré dans l'âge
exactement ça mais les premiers
symptômes manille ferme la porte ouais
[Rires]
je parle d'un réel je parle à tout le
monde tout le monde s'en fout on ferme
jamais les portes quand je parle d'actes
mais on s'en fout irak jeudi comme
n'importe quel sacrifice entre la porte
c'est là que j'ai vu que c'était grave
et là il m'a dit j'ai malingre
déshabille toi
notre matériel professionnel là j'ai
tout mangé l'à-propos l'état la tension
tout ah bah ouais c'est pas pour dire
vous avez le taux d'oxygène dans le
doigt soyez de chinois
se sert du doigt
elle le sait à un moment parce que
j'étais ici et je prenais mon taux
d'oxygène toutes les secondes mais
toutes les dix minutes drogba est mieux
c'est ma passion des hypocondriaques non
ce médecin bah oui ça
me rassure toi même
[Rires]
sans manette il m'en donne un peu envie
de
fonder y prenaient des initiatives qui à
l'heure par exemple moi je vous ai dit
que j'avais des petits divers rigole ça
va donner ton truc dit lors pas dit non
non la vérité peut-être ses fins dit la
vérité ne dit pas ce que je vous dis pas
ce que je fais
par téléphone je l'aï eu au téléphone ce
week end et comment ça l'est parce que
toute la semaine des rougeurs tu aurais
je trahir un secret médical j'ai eu des
vertiges toute la semaine j'ai fait
l'émission mais j'étais pas bien et donc
je lui ai dit écoute ça continue je
confirme les yeux je tente ma chance et
il m'a donné poser un diagnostic
les munichois tant que toujours mais
voilà c'est quoi aujourd'hui mais bien
c'est que j'avais des calories mais lui
avait prescrit des médailles non mais
pas encore mais j'attends de voir les
aiguilles alors que je dis je dis attend
de voir la cesci jeudi là et faire des
analyses de m'envoyer les analyses et je
voterai donc pour beaucoup attendre
beaucoup à attendre dans votre
traitement a bien fait d'attendre évoqué
ceni alors moi j'ai attendu toi tu as
attendu l'avait vu ce que j'ai fait vous
avez puisque je
ne me sens pas bien ce que vous fermez
la porte de veules cloche chez vous
sortirez votre grossetête aux scop
[Applaudissements]
vous c'est pas médecin qu'il vous faut
c'est un pompier
avec une grosse france
info vous fait peur avec vos médicaments
parce qu'on vous a entendu dire que vous
avez mis du curé dans votre bain sur
youtube quoi sert une écurie de curry
dans votre matelas est ce que c'est les
mêmes envies de mode pour soigner les
chroniqueurs ça me fait peur
alexa loo dire la vérité c'est c'est un
ami ouais c'est qui je peux pas bien à
mes cuisiniers visiblement
les médecins ami rappeur qui m'a donné
cette technique et ça fait ça sérieux et
j'ai mis du curry dont ben
j'étais comme ça j'étais en poulet
tandoori
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais du fury partout autour de moi
même pas du tout dans la baignoire
ajouté cammas est un moment clé chez
même une couche est donc j'ai pause j'ai
jeté dans le bain
et je vous jure que ses pairs dans le
goulet ça fait quoi le curry pour la
musique c'est bon c'est bon les maisons
pour paraît que c'est moi c'est toi
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a dit je vais fait
moi je réponds pays voilà je sache
verger de curé sur le banc
oui mais voilà attendant on se moque
mais est ce que tu as été voir médecin
pas tendres mais voilà donc tu l'a
écoutée chaque année des sous tu m'as le
médecin n'ont pas besoin vous est ce que
le rallye ce vous avez des symptômes je
vais très bien d'accord merci vous sait
pas parler ma troisième couilles
c'est une sorte de furoncles en fait
mais je connais ça allait ou
vraiment entre les allées de boules les
deux bouts regardée alors que je regarde
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment moi c'est les problèmes
d'oreille henry gauche ah ben je vous
entends mal parfois à l'arrêt harry bas
il faut venir me voir je vais venir mais
vous avez un cabinet où c'est uniquement
en loge l'horloge
compte ramener votre carte vitale
mais on peut venir se passait chez vous
ben moi j'ai une première fouille dans
la marine en matière est câline bull ici
à mouchamps train de regarder c'est un
kyste à priori j'ai regardé dans la foi
à mon avis c'est bénin c'est doux c'est
un du temps
médical long terme médical au modem
[Rires]
c'est pas l'aude m ces lots des bleus
dès lors un peu dans l'eau ter est
heureux et lolo le don louvain braine
l'alleud d'être
compris c'est rien du tout je vous dis
ça c'est rien du tout c'est organique
c'est rien du tout a commencé avec
petite ponction
si elle est gênée je suis obligé de
faire une ponction voudrait des
fonctions bien chargé des fonctions de
la fiche de paye
[Rires]
avec
moi je souhaitais c'est du bouche à
bouche
à tous alors vous aussi là bas c'est
l'autre cabinet resserré bon ça ça pour
être votre style père quand
non moyens aliments mène à buckingham
avec une grotte cela vous dirai non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]